coming up next week at the Strasburg
plenary tea tip a Mongolian presidential
visit relations with Russia and FIFA
corruption welcome to the agenda for as
many advantages they've been as many
disadvantages but the tease it
merry-go-round isn't over yet with the
ink barely dry on last week's trade
committee report political families are
suiting and booting up to do battle
again and the culprit behind the
kerfuffle the investor state dispute
mechanism or isds the socialist will
table in the mend meant to exclude isds
from t tip and move there would no doubt
tickle the fancy of the greens with cap
call the socialist for doing a dirty
deal on isds last week but the biggest
group in the house the European People's
Party are in favor of the text adopted
by the trade committee would they then
vote against an amended text and don't
forget that this is most likely the roll
call vote meaning the public will be
able to see how each and every mep vote
could that have an impact keep your eyes
peeled is going to be a firecracker on
wednesday it took an almighty push but
the reign of serb latter as the
president of FIFA is finally at an end
he was forced to resign at following a
corruption scandal engulfing the world
football body despite saying he see
the FBI investigation which led to
multiple arrests has finally emboldened
the EU to think about taking action to
promote solid change and root out
corruption in football at the plenary
representatives from the Commission and
member states will discuss possible
avenues forward with any PS on Wednesday
Tuesday sees a presidential address from
which country mongolia europe's been
developing its relations with mongolia
for a quarter century most likely the
president will discuss deepening
economic and political ties with the EU
to loosen the grip of Russia and China
find out what's a theogony lübeck has to
say when he addresses mep on tuesday
nearest relations with Russia are at an
all-time low could a Russian black plays
lead to more sanctions for Russia 89
politicians and military officials
including the former UK deputy prime
minister nick clegg were banned from
entering russia this all comes on the
eve of the g7 summit previously called
the g8 summit when Russia had a place at
the table what should Europe do next
with his neighbor follow the debate on
Wednesday with a vote on Thursday we've
probably all got a funny story to tell
when it comes to gathering round the
table for a family dinner but if you've
ever wondered what a family dinner looks
like an Ecuador mine marled Jordan get
yourself down to the parliamentarian for
a photo exhibition by the World Food
Programme and that's what we have with
this agenda take care and enjoy the week